the very first famous person that I ever
knew about that used Evernote was Ed
Catmull the head of Pixar created
creativity he was on an episode what
episode number Jackie put in the notes
creativity yeah 78 which is a fundament
which is one of the books that's like
most fundamental to my thinking about
alternate well you have to watch this
two-part episode I did he's amazing
episode 65 he wrote me a letter he wrote
me a note years and years ago right at
the beginning of Evernote I get a letter
from Ed Catmull it was already been a
hero of mine
we had just released a new version of
Evernote and he wrote me at this email
was basically like 20 things that he
hated about the new version of Evernote
and I was like holy crap getting notes
from the guy who create Orion yeah like
Ed Catmull knows about Evernote and uses
it enough to actually like have a strong
negative opinion about the new changes
you made so I could ran around the
office showed everyone and yeah and his
whole thesis in creativity ink writers
creativity is a process it isn't this
thing that like it's not a bolt of
lightning
that's irreproducible there's the myth
in again Silicon Valley startup culture
that you know there's the myth of like
the lone cowboy founder there's the myth
of the irreproducible
creativity there's the myth of the you
know it's the way that Mark Zuckerberg I
think described Twitter right which I
think he said Twitter is a clown car
that fell into a gold mine yeah all of
that is kind of true but it's also super
inefficient you can structure things you
can you can be a big company that that
has discipline and structure in order to
make innovative creative things on time
on budget on schedule like Pixar does
like Netflix does or you can be a big
company like HP that has a structure
that's meant to inhibit innovation so
that they don't actually like innovate
stuff because they're playing defense
because they're trying to protect their
their existing product base yeah so just
because most big tech companies are
structured to inhibit innovation because
they don't want to disrupt their
lucrative business doesn't mean that
that's the only way you can set up a big
tech company so we're trying to set it
up the way that Netflix did so we want
to do to the tech industry what Netflix
did for the entertainment industry got
it so what's in it for the creator's
then because the creator's have visions
of grandeur and they would like to take
their company public hit a hundred
million in revenue get bought out
whatever yes some of them do and some of
them want to make important products
we're all done benefit and benefit
financially when they're successful
those are the ones revenue share with
the creators equity so everything we do
is set up under the hood as a as a
separate legal entity so they have
equity in it we could spin them out or
we could sell them where we can operate
we can profit share it's similar to how
like I don't think you can say that like
if you're one of the top most again
brilliant animators or filmmakers like
you want to go and make your thing at
HBO or at Netflix or XR and like you're
gonna have upside and you're gonna have
the the creative control you can have
the success so that's what we're looking
for for product people yeah if someone
who's trying to optimize for the
illusion of how much independence they
have yeah it's just not the right
motivation